how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
calendar where we talk about all things
Marvel MCU and sometimes DC as well and
today we have news about both the DC
extended universe and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe now it's been a
pretty rough year so far 20/20 hasn't
been kind and it hasn't been kind to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe either phase 4
has been pushed back and then San Diego
comic-con was canceled the event that
everybody looks forward to the entire
year but then there was a little bit of
hope because Comic Con announced that
they were going to be doing a Comic Con
at home and this got fans excited
because we thought we might see
something from Marvel Studios however
unfortunately we have heard that they're
going to be sitting this year out in a
recent report today from deadline.com
they say we hear Marvel is sitting on
the sidelines and that Warner Brothers
feature side of DC will hold their goods
for their own virtual fan confab in
August so Marvel and DC won't be
attending comic-con at home but there is
some good news that comes along with us
DC for example is not attending
comic-con at home because they are
having their own event they're having DC
fandom and it's basically their own huge
comic-con but it's only going to be
about DC and all the major people are
going to participate gal gadot is going
to be there to talk about Wonder Woman
1984 Zack Snyder is going to be there to
talk about the Justice League Snyder cut
and many more people as well so if
you're a fan of DC there's a lot of
exclusive things coming at DC's fandom
and the fact that Marvel Studios is
sitting this comic-con at home out means
that they may be planning to do their
own event as well there's been rumors
about this happening although nothing is
confirmed yet but this would actually be
much better than a comic-con at home and
the reason is normally Marvel only gets
a certain amount of time at San Diego
comic-con to talk about whatever they
want to talk about they can only show so
much but if they do their own event it
can be however long they want it to be
and they could show whatever they want
this includes new footage new trailers
they could announce new phase four
projects or they could even announce
some things that are coming in phase
five they could even bring in new actors
that they've already assigned to play
different MCU roles and perhaps even
reveal some new characters come in to
the MCU such as Kristen bales a
mysterious character that is
to be plain and Thor love and thunder so
yes it is a bummer that Marvel Studios
is not going to be attending SD CC at
home but it would be better for them to
have their own event let's just hope
that the rumors are true and this is
what Marvel Studios is planning after
all DC is doing their own event and that
may Chev them to want to do their own
event as well as something for the fans
since we haven't really gotten anything
in almost a year now so it's a bummer
but let me know what you would think
about Marvel Studios doing their own
event and if they did that what would
you like to see let me know your
thoughts about this in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU and DC
news as well for live updates you can
follow me on Twitter and as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof woof